your parents like being grandparents
they love being grandparents it's it's
like yeah I've never seen them happier
and they we're at this thing now we're
like I don't know if it happened for you
but I've seen not just watching them
with my son but like my relationship
with my own parents is different like I
I feel like my dad treats me differently
like for years and years he was like you
know like I was a little boy still he
was like hey buddy how's it going
everything all right buddy and then it
just was like that little childish talk
and then now he's like I like when women
wear lace bras so you can see their
nipples like I don't ever want to know
that about you man or like he's a
Vietnam vet yeah and for a long time I
miss is a horrible thing to ask a
stranger but he's my dad so I would when
I was a kid I'd be like did you ever
kill anybody in a war yeah and he said
no and then as a teenager I asked him
again he was like no it just it didn't
happen and then years later I said so
you're in this war and you never killed
anybody
and he goes I threw grenades and the
bunkers
and I go were there people in there he
was there work yeah but not anymore
and then this year I go did you ever
kill anybody he goes there's no better
feeling than killing the enemy that's
that's the nice arc of closeness you're
getting with your dad my god especially
that's better than like the birth of you
were you when you were born it was great
but no killing the enemy yeah okay and
seeing some nipple through some lace bra
that's the top of the cake that really
is a full day yeah that's a good day
you